le rainbow warrior qui en pleine nuit il
ya 20 ans coulé dans le port d'auckland
un scandale qui aura de profondes
répercussions
après des années de pas citer on sait
désormais que lors de cette opération de
sabotage pour empêcher les militants de
greenpeace de perturber les essais
nucléaires de mururoa vient cette horde
a bel et bien été donnée au plus haut
niveau
l'amiral lacoste la firme l'accord
venait de françois mitterrand lui-même
philippe visseyrias marie cazaux
christophe pignol au large des côtes
néo-zélandaises repose une épave dont le
nom rappelle l'un des fiascos les plus
retentissants des services secrets
français
le rainbow warrior le 10 juillet 1985 en
rade d'auckland en nouvelle-zélande deux
bombes et ventre le bateau de
l'organisation écologiste greenpeace
elles ont été posées quelques heures
plus tôt par des nageurs de combat de la
dgse les services secrets français le
gouvernement français voulait ainsi
empêcher greenpeace de perturber ses
essais nucléaires dans le pacifique
je devais être un simple sabotage mais
un photographe de greenpeace fernando
pereira meurt dans l'explosion
pour nous c'était un acte de terrorisme
d'état
nous avons été extrêmement choqué jamais
nous n'aurions imaginé que le
gouvernement français en viendrait à
faire sauter l'un de nos bateaux à
auckland
l'émotion est immense dans les jours qui
suivent deux agents secrets français
sont interpellés il voyageait sous une
fausse identité
ils ont des passeports suisse et
prétendent s'appelait alain et sophie tu
ranges mais les faux époux tu ranges
sont démasqués leurs vrais noms sont
rendus publics commandant à la maaf art
et capitaine dominique prieur
ils seront par la suite condamné puis
expulsé de nouvelle zélande
des années plus tard dominique prieur
acceptera de parler de cette mission si
particulière les délais qui nous est
imparti était réduit donc
il a fallu travailler dans mieux dans
des conditions qui n'étaient pas
toujours faciles et j'avais le sentiment
que peut-être des choses allaient se
compliquer aucun service pendant deux
mois
charles hernu le ministre de la défense
va nier toute implication de la france
dans l'attentât mais l' enquête
progresse les journaux font révélations
sur révélations le 20 septembre
charles hernu est contraint à la
démission le lendemain laurent fabius
alors premier ministre intervient en
direct au journal de 20 heures ce sont
des agents de la dgse qui ont coulé ce
bateau ils ont agi sur ordre mais sur
ordre de qui l'amiral lacoste dirigeait
à l'époque la dgse pour lui françois
mitterrand était au courant de ce projet
d'attentât depuis le départ j'ai tenu
personnellement à vérifier auprès de lui
que ce n'était pas seulement une
initiative de son ministre de la défense
et que à charles hernu lui en avait bien
parlé et il m'a confirmé qu'il était
bien au courant voilà pourtant pas d'
enquête parlementaire
le silence retombe après la démission de
charles hernu la droite et la gauche ont
pas voulu d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire
parce que ça les obliger à montrer du
doigt les amiraux généraux tout ce qui
est le lobby militaire aujourd'hui la
fille du photographe mort dans le
sabotage du rainbow warrior dit n'avoir
jamais reçu d'excusés officielles de la
part de la france il ya quelques jours
voilà ce qu'elle confie à greenpeace
de nombreux agents secrets français
s'ils avaient participé à cette
opération ont échappé à la prison
ce n'est pas la justice voilà ce que
nous pensons avec ma famille
après la sphère du rainbow warrior
greenpeace vie sa popularité renforcer
dans le monde entier à l'opposé la
france discréditer dû réorganiser
complètement ses services secrets